Many of you probably heard the big news
about the Boy Scouts, this was a big story.
Last week the organization decided
to allow girls to join
and they officially changed their name to just Scouts.
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Cool.
Now of course.
Course a lot of people have opinions about this
and they're wondering if making the organization co-ed
is a good idea.
We haven't talked about it yet
what do you think Andy?
Well I don't want to swing anyone's opinion
but I did get my hands on some footage
from the co-ed Scout camp.
I think a lot of you will find it very troubling.
Take a look.
(fire crackling)
(dramatic music)
What the.
Which one of you did this?
(audience laughing)
Oops.
Hi I'm Andy Richter
and I'm here to talk to you about implicit bias.
If you watched that clip
and assumed the owner of the curling iron would be a girl
then you just showed implicit bias.
Something to think about.
Okay I think we got it.
Let's give it up for my camera operator Sam.
(applauding)
Thanks Andy.
Hi me again.
If you assumed my camera operator Sam was a man
you've once again shown implicit bias.
Check your bias.
Okay guys we're really done now.
I have to take my car to the mechanic.
Yes.
My mechanic is a woman, damn it people this is exhausting.
I'm spending the rest of my day
fighting against gender inequality.
(audience cheering)
Hi I'm Conan O'Brien
and if you really thought Andy
was gonna spend the afternoon on activism
instead of taking his usual nap,
then you just showed implicit bias.
Hi I'm Andy Richter
and if you thought Conan wasn't going to be
a grade A douche bag about this
then you showed implicit bias.
Hi I'm Conan O'Brien
and if you thought Andy wasn't gonna get way too emotional
and overreact to my teasing then you--
Hi I'm Andy Richter
and if you thought this sketch was better
before Conan inserted himself into it then you--
Hi I'm Conan O'Brien and I'm sorry
but the last time I checked the show's called Conan.
Hi I'm Conan O'Brien and oh damn it!
(Conan laughing)
Shut up!
You're so sensitive.
Because you're always undermining me!
Hi I'm Tony Hale.
And I'm here to promote the new season
of Arrested Development available May 29th on Netflix.
That's right, this whole thing
was an elaborate marketing ploy.
If you thought it was a comedy sketch (laughs)
then you've just shown implicit bias.
(audience cheering)
I have no idea what just happened.